foreign
you're also an epidemiologist I presume
the prospect of a viral pandemic keeps
you up at night as well no opening with
a reminder of how terrible the covid
pandemic was just so we can all be
properly terrified by the possibility of
the even more dangerous fungal pandemic
that's about to be introduced as if I
didn't have enough to be pessimistic
about I could now add fungus zombies to
the list great also the 1968 title card
might be the most unnecessary title card
to ever title card I think the plethora
of cigarettes in 29 different shades of
beige gave us all the context clues we
required also the third discount John
hey holy Four Weddings in a funeral
bacteria no you like saying no would you
prefer he said yes and lied is this show
on Fox News permanently fixed on one
unifying goal to spread the infection to
every last human alive slightly more
Angry Peter Capaldi here must be a fun
guy at parties I mean he doesn't really
leave mushroom for optimism does he if I
was watching this live I'd switch over
to the nearest sports channel
you're using fungi instead of blood and
different music doesn't make this any
less of a discount Game of Thrones intro
having to be reminded that 2003 was 20
years ago if you keep making me feel
like an ancient one this will be the
last of me watching this series and as
if this title card wasn't enough this
shot alone is an absolute orgy of
evidence that not only is this a Young
Person's room but also that this is a
Young Person's room from the mid-oughts
coming straight from drinking orange
juice to Coffee despite all the warnings
and clerks too I'm pretty sure even 8am
would be more appetizing you can get
your homework done Pedro Pascal is not
my daddy in this scene concrete guy's
gonna be there yeah they said maybe
maybe I didn't expect the Venn diagram
consisting of characters who have a
passion for concrete and characters who
are complicated father figures would
ever overlap to include Gerard Butler
Tom Hardy and Pedro Pascal but here we
are sniff testing your leftovers I mean
I know we all do it but just like my
grandpa used to say it doesn't have to
be wiffy to make your tummy squiffy what
kind of masochist in 2003 would use this
classic phone case with the belt clip
which made you look super super [__]
cool by the way but still put the phone
in their pocket your t-shirt's inside
out
oh man that is so annoying but at least
as they can't get any worse going
through your father's drawers trust me
that is asking for trouble and she's
very lucky that the show's commitment to
portraying a wholesome relationship
conflicted with her finding well just go
through your parents drawers and find
out for yourself TV since it's not
actually recommend doing three parent
stores and will not be held liable for
any resulting injury nightmares or lost
respect for any family members involved
dad you love biscuits I do
but I'm on Atkins I swear shows
mentioning the Atkins diet is to the
mid-auts with Bayesian cigarettes are to
the 60s Expo bum positional stickers in
case you confused it with Austin
Minnesota and literally any other time
in 2003 why the [__] does it matter that
it's September why are you telling me
this now Macbeth no I don't hate
Shakespeare I just wish we'd teach kids
about the fun ones like Hamlet homework
is due end of class tomorrow well if the
homework's due at the end of class then
that's classwork there is nothing in
that description that would encourage me
to spend any time with that assignment
at home you should go home panicking in
front of a child and telling them they
should go home but not actually telling
them why they need to go home what the
[__] random lady people out there need
to get right with Jesus three Nails Plus
One cross equals four given yep that's
the way to get the kids into Jesus math
I was thinking we'd make some cookies
chocolate chip
math and raisin cookies I feel the Lord
also I always find it odd when people
spin this kind of religious rhetoric in
the face of violence and death because
the Bible might be the most violent book
that has ever existed all the effort
that went into making me believe it's
2003 just to blow it all by including
2005's murder ball this is some amazing
background suspense that reminds me of
the library scene in it chapter one
regardless of whether you've played the
game or know where this is going or have
no knowledge whatsoever these few
seconds set up the horror of what's to
come perfectly dog knows that she's
about to go down before any of the
humans do and is briefly acknowledged
But ultimately ignored cliche also sure
the dog's acting weird and whatnot but
what we really should be focused on is
how horribly organized this bookcase is
it's [__] chaos comment today from
the Austin Police Department regarding a
rash of violent incidents across the
city the only thing worse than using
random news position to explain what's
going on is having one of our characters
not paying attention to the random news
position where's the cake
for getting cake what makes for getting
the cake even worse though is that
you're gonna be stuck eating raisin
cookies Joel also shows that pile on the
undomesticated dad who's useless at
looking after himself and relies on the
little kid good at life routine this
heavily are screaming from the rooftops
that something is going to happen to
said kid and yes maybe there were only
four people watching this who didn't
know it was coming but they deserve to
be surprised traumatized too Mrs Adler
because [__] the TV the dog and the
clearly freaked out shopkeeper that have
all told me to stay home instead I'm
gonna wander into my neighbor's house
that has no Britain and blood all over
because I'm only smart when my dad needs
to look dumb look mananoki could be a
fungi infected zombie but there's also a
strong possibility she's just getting
Mrs Adler back for choosing to make
raisin cookies instead of chocolate chip
I mean who the [__] chooses to make
raisin cookies
Grandma Sophia Portobello is nice enough
to stop chasing Sarah just long enough
for Joel to show up Park get out of the
truck grab Sarah and get ready to attack
get the truck right now also convenient
Joel conveniently has a weapon in his
hand when he exits the truck despite
having no way of knowing Sarah was in
trouble the fungicidal Nana Maniac
hadn't even left the house yet
no one will be seated as Joel and Tommy
decide aloud which interstates and
highways they will be taking to get out
of town how do you know we're not sick
I'm saying it's mostly people in the
city mostly it's Jimmy's Place I might
carry more weight if I had the first
clue who Jimmy was you couldn't have
given us a scene with Jimmy instead of
confirming that kids get bored at school
everybody had the same [__] idea to
take a major roadway out of the city
yeah that's so weird Tommy you might
think it's the subtle nods like this
backseat POV scene that inspired people
to call this the best video game
adaptation of all time but I would like
instead to refer you to the person whose
POV we are seeing this from Nico Parker
along with Pascal and basically every
damn person in the pilot gives such
sincere and engaging performances that
this jumps from being a great pilot
based on a video game to Simply a great
pilot that just happens to be based on a
video game head of the river I'll find a
way a way that wasn't climbing over the
car but instead had to result in the
being separated all so that he can Tommy
ex machina them a few scenes from now
well one of them at least I realize
these aren't technically zombies but
there are still moments like this that
feel right out of a Walking Dead episode
maybe it's impossible to escape that
comparison but I'm me so you're still
getting us in yes sir
military sent to protect the people from
viral outbreak actually ends up mostly
being there to kill people whether
they've contracted the virus or not
cliche come on baby because I gotta get
you okay okay three sin removals might
seem excessive for one video but this is
likely the only opportunity I'm gonna
get to remove Us in for one of the best
video game prologues ever committed to
disc and either way Pedro Nails this
scene oh so now you don't give us a
specific year likely because the show
doesn't want to date itself when we get
to season four and wonder why it's still
2023 but in that case don't [__] date
the earlier scenes we know how time
works also damn these sudden time jumps
in their ability to strip all the
momentum out of a story yeah yeah their
hands were tied by the video game but
guess what they're not do what you want
wouldn't have been interesting to see
how Joel deals with the loss of his
daughter in the opening months and years
of the Apocalypse all you've done now is
left the door open for a disappointing
spin-off called oh I don't know let's
say Fear The Last of Us no one wants
eight seasons of that this is clearly
trying to tease us into thinking that
we're seeing a fully infected
individuals stumbling along but we know
that the fully infected move quickly so
why give us a slow zombie stumble tease
unless of course you want us to keep
thinking we're watching The Walking Dead
and we really don't want to be watching
The Walking Dead Schindler's red
Petticoat oh so now you're giving us the
year now what was the point
where they did the thing and why is the
same
this even time it is what year it is who
cares this is the biggest list of
symptoms I've ever seen these could be a
sign of anything from slight
intoxication to having a nap at a weird
point of the day that now means you're
too awake to go back to bed at a
sensible time so you stay up until 5am
playing video games and just resign
yourself to being a nocturnal Beast it's
me I'm the nocturnal Beast
also this is great information for the
audience and I'm sure it won't backfire
when a snarky YouTube channel takes a
screenshot to make sure it's totally
obeyed by the show in the future
how did you get this and now we have
another scene of a child dying to
demonstrate how Bleak the situation is
and call me a wimp but I think two child
deaths in less than three minutes may be
pushing me to my HBO Max tomorrow we got
street sweeping
or swimming house
which pays more
maybe the one with the [__] this is
Boston where Yankees fans have always
told me that there is [__] in the
streets so that didn't answer the
question he asked Gore Lieberman shirts
in 2023 and yes I understand the world
has been out of the shirt making
business for 20 years but I'm not buying
anyone was wearing those shirts in 2003
either
[Music]
I don't have a hard time believing that
an overzealous military State could
bring back the death penalty I can also
buy that they do it publicly to inspire
fear and obedience from those pesky
masses but people still have a choice
not to turn up right it just seems so
strange to me that an entire crowd would
turn up for this [__] not just the
occasional sociopath looking for the
light in the darkness is great for the
Green Lantern Corps but in this world I
imagine it's pretty terrible advice I
bet more times than not that light will
be attached to a speeding car a freight
train or an assault rifle
Tess survives this
I just realized in this universe the
fungi infection spreading was probably
why Firefly was canceled and not because
of the terrible Fox Executives to the
sin and as always is network television
seven eight
you kids hey there's a line This is the
sole objection we hear to the man
skipping a very long line of people all
wishing to send messages to their loved
ones 73k Orlando out Florida show me
where the tower is you can't be serious
Joel it's in Wyoming Wyoming
Joel managed to find his stash in a
matter of seconds instead of having to
inspect every item in the room jump into
some walls pick up some random cup
retrace the steps drop some random cup
restart the day and then finally resort
to checking Google it's just not
realistic reading physical maps I mean
the fungi couldn't wait till after the
iPhone was invented in 2007 what a
fungal ass
pushing your partner over to get in bed
instead of just getting into the bed on
the other side it's Miracle you're alive
there's a very Millennials are alive
Tess would be excellent On The Fringe of
TV sins I mean she would be a regular
mind Hunter oh come on you want me to go
back to the mushroom puns also in a tour
of rocks in isn't it enough things that
may be the biggest sin in television
well except for that 90s show I mean why
the [__] does that exist
[Music]
Robert is terrified of you so you march
out of here all Clint Eastwood he's
going to get wind of it and Skip how
does she even know Robert is still alive
remember that this [__] happened it's
five for 20 years and you get nowhere
you're not a rebellion
spray paint because having people talk
about the Rebellion actiony stuff is so
much better than actually showing the
Rebellion actiony stuff did 47 years of
Walking Dead on a farm not teach show
writers anything this
I believe it is that is not an answer at
least not an answer that would result in
me agreeing to abandon what little
semblance of home I have at the risk of
being hanged whatever you need whatever
it takes look at her where she needs to
go scenes like this drive me mad Kim's
immediate and unquestioning commitment
here just shows that we could have saved
all of the time if Marlene had just
opened with whatever is on the slip of
paper instead of burying the lead and
expositing us to death I won't tell
anyone about any of this I swear where
are you gonna go this is a valid
question where does Ellie think she
could go we're gonna find out she's
carrying the infection but not showing
any of the symptoms but anywhere she
goes once they check her with the scanny
doodad they'll shoot her on site and not
ask any questions Emily should know this
so seriously where is she trying to go
[Applause]
episode promised a showdown between Joel
and Robert but chooses to kill off
Robert before it could happen no fear
that was a lot of gunfire
a lot of gunfire that neither Joel nor
Tess heard while they were crawling
through the walls so I think you're okay
I can do it you don't have a [__]
here on your [__] head could you
please
[Laughter]
you get her there safely and I'll give
you what you need filled up
guns supplies all of it I know Marlene
is low on options but isn't promising
Joel a truck and a load of weapons and
supplies giving away exactly how
valuable Ellie is to someone who isn't
exactly part of the cause she just said
and I know what you're both capable of
for better or worse so wouldn't it be
better to trust one ear cam to get the
job done rather than Joel who might be
motivated to hold her for an even higher
Ransom also despite that it sure is
lucky that Marlene is spontaneously
gifted with Joel man who just happens to
have a lost daughter the same age as
Ellie and will use that trauma to
protect her with an instinctual Fury you
are all that matters my team will not
jeopardize that well that suggests that
her team knows exactly why Ellie is so
important so how many [__] people
know about this super secret secret at
least importance is becoming less of a
secret and more of a this is definitely
going to end up getting Ellie kidnapped
and Marlene will wonder where it all
went wrong situation also if Marlene was
taking Ellie yourself why would she even
need to risk telling the team why she's
so important shouldn't they just follow
her orders
says the person that just picked us up
so what's the deal with you anyways some
kind of bigwig's daughter or something
something like that okay I know I send
Marlene for letting on how special Ellie
is but at the same time now that she's
trusted her with Joel and Tess why
didn't she just tell them exactly why
she's so special like what if they spot
or bite and have a huge freak out and
decide to kill her I kept saying like
wake me up before you go go
using Wham as your choice of an 80s
reference 80s means trouble code broken
listen no Joel you listen if you didn't
want your code broken maybe don't leave
two-thirds of the cipher inside the damn
cipher book holy [__] I'm actually
outside neither Joel nor Tas thought it
would be smart to prompt the child who's
never been outside to not do [__] like
this once outside
for the record we don't ever need to see
someone urinating like ever really man
yep you're doing this by the book and
here's a great example of when it would
be extremely beneficial for Joel and
Tess to have some knowledge of Ellie's
condition [__] Marlene and Ellie
pilot does not contain nearly enough
rearranging of pallets
do you have any
molds and fungus stop all the clocks cut
off the telephone prevent the dog from
barking with a juicy bone concrete guy
is going to be there yeah they said
maybe you do it for the air that will be
displaced and most of all you do it for
the [__] concrete because it is
delicate as blood you really have come
mod the voicemail box of Sterling Archer
is full goodbye idiot God damn it
are you aiming for these people
okay you're okay you're gonna be okay
you have been found guilty by the Elders
of the town of uttering the name of our
Lord
and so as a blessed fever you are to be
stoned to death I want you to forget
this ever happened okay lines up
straight like that right to the right of
it and to the left of it are Pockets
right in those pockets of money look in
either one of them pay the bill
there not even supposed to be here today
on a daily basis I consume enough drugs
to sedate Manhattan Long Island and
queens for a month so let's go hunt that
Knocker down
and get our battery and our truck
and then we'll go find Tommy
this is the way Brightest Day
in Blackest Night
no evil fellas gave my side if you want
me to look for the light and I'll break
your jaw
I won't tell anyone about any of this
where are you gonna go where are you
gonna go where are you gonna run Where
Are You Gonna hide